kommen wir zu einem anderen thema es ist
ein ganz seltsamer kampf der derzeit in
deutschlands jagdrevieren gekämpft wird
unbekannte zerstörten dort reihenweise
jäger hochsitze alleine in den wäldern
rund um frankfurt haben sie in den
vergangenen wochen dutzende dieser
hochsitze völlig zerstörte umgestürzt
teilweise sogar niedergebrannt darüber
waren wir sprechen mit markus stifter
vom hessischen jagdverband er steht an
einem dieser hochsitze guten abend herr
stifter ja vielleicht können sie uns
sagen wer steckt dahinter
schönen guten abend erstmal ja wir sehen
hier im hintergrund eine dieser kann es
in die heruntergebrannt sind in diesem
jahr wir waren es insgesamt 17 stück im
gesamtraum großraum frankfurt insgesamt
sogar 72 stück bei der hinter steckt
kann man noch nicht genau sagen sind an
verschiedenen hochsitzen ein sieg die
signets von der af der anime liberation
front gefunden worden
aber die ermittlungen der polizei
richten sich momentan noch in alle
richtungen animal liberation front steht
dort auch auf den schildern sie wird
dort gerade eingeblendet sehen sind dass
tierschützer und was würden sie denen
gerne entgegnet vielleicht wollen sie
auch die arbeit eines jägers noch mal
erklären
also wenn wir uns überlegen die als
jäger haben natürlich hier einen
gesetzlichen auftrag auch zu erfüllen
das heißt wir haben festgesetzte
abschusszahlen wir müssen eine bestimmte
anzahl an wildtieren auch erlegen
gerade jetzt insbesondere in der krise
muss auch darum geht den waldumbau zu
fördern oder auch die solchen
einschleppung zum beispiel wie die sbb
in einer ausbreitung zu verhindern
deshalb sind wir darauf angewiesen dass
wir solche ansitz einrichtungen haben
also man kann das von unseren
gesetzlichen auftrag vergleichen das ist
ähnlich zum beispiel wie bei den
rettungsdiensten oder bei der feuerwehr
was welcher übernehmen und das ist eine
ganz wichtige aufgabe und was ich ganz
gerne jetzt im prinzip auch an
sympathisanten dieser gruppen richten
würde wäre einfachen weil soll
berücksichtigen hier hatte mal ein
großes glück ja an dieser stelle wo wir
stehen
wir stehen zwischen zwei
naturschutzgebieten und von
tierschützern müsste das doch eigentlich
klar sein wenn ich hier einen brandherd
letztendlich läge der wahrscheinlich
sogar mit brandbeschleuniger hier
letztendlich zu diesem schnellen
entfachen des feuers geführt hat und nur
durch das umsichtige handeln eines
berufstätigen der morgens und vier hier
schon unterwegs war konnte verhindert
werden dass die teuer
aber sehr schnell vor ort und konnten
ein übergreifen der flammen auf das
naturschutzgebiet verhindern
und da wären wichtige brutstätten für
eine ganze menge vogelarten auch für
junghasen und rehkitze wären hier
verloren gegangen die werden
wahrscheinlich in den schlamm dann
untergegangen
das ist ja alles was ich doch mal sind
der kamera sieht aber rundherum ist
alles gras als es wäre sehr schnell
gegangen ein großer scheck spürte
schließt sich hier noch an
das hätte also sehr grob ein großes
feuer entfachen können manipulierte
hochsitze können ja auch ganz schnell zu
einer großen gefahr für jäger werden wie
gehen sie da jetzt weiter vor wie kann
man das beobachten was insbesondere wenn
die hose zu manipuliert werden das heißt
wenn sie angelegt werden müssen unsere
kollegen natürlich sehr sehr vorsichtig
sein jedem sitz vor dem besteigen
nochmal genau kontrollieren dann würde
sich nämlich schon einmal eine versuchte
körperverletzung oder sogar eine schwere
oder gefährliche körperverletzung
handeln wenn dann tatsächlich dann
jemand abstürzt und sich dann da und
dann dabei zu schaden kommt jetzt haben
wir hier wir halt sehen eine große
zerstörung vorsitz kann man ungefähr
zwischen 500 und 1000 euro schaden
ausgehen in frankfurt alleine waren es
20.000 euro die an schaden entstanden
sind im stadtwald da darf man auch immer
nicht vergessen dieser schaden der bei
einer kommune entsteht wird letztendlich
von der gesamtgesellschaft über
steuergelder nachher zu finanzieren
seien
markus stifter vom hessischen
jagdverband vielen herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch
dankeschön